if you want to learn how les brown Casey
Neistat
and Will Smith make a lot of money by
not chasing money then this video is for
you don't just do it for the money the
vast majority of the work that I do
including here on YouTube I get paid for
but it definitely is not why I show up
what's that believe nation it seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see Unleashed
out into the world I started the one
rule series to try to pick up on some of
the most common rules that are said over
over and over again by the people we
profile and so today we're gonna learn
how to not chase money enjoy when I
speak it's not about me my prayer is
more of the less of me I'm encouraging
people who are serious about speaking
don't just do it for the money you can
make a lot of money I earn more in one
hour than 90% of the American public
earn working for five years mm-hmm
but when you find something that you
love you will study it something that
you love it becomes a difference between
being and speaking and speaking being in
you that you will become not just
confident but you'll become competent on
that so like 10 o'clock last night I was
at the gym getting swole I was listening
to a guy named Dan Ariely who's a
behavioral economist he was talking
about why we worked in his entire sort
of thesis was predicated on the idea
that we work because we want to not
because we have to it made me think
about my YouTube channel and the fact
that I've made like 600 videos in the
last couple of years and how much I and
all the things I don't get to do in life
because I'm so focused on my work
vast majority of the work that I do
including here on YouTube I get paid for
but it definitely is not why I show up I
get it out of this like longing or
hunger for accomplishment or this idea
of needing to complete something
professor I was listening to he equates
it to like climbing a mountain which is
a perfectly it's an appropriate analogy
because I love climbing mountains look
here is a picture of me and my homie
Graham at a nearly 23,000 feet above sea
level
my brother van put that note in there
right after we got back so why don't we
climb mountains I don't get paid to
climb mountains it's not fun do I look
too happy then I'm not happy I'm close
to death right there we climb mountains
for the same reason that we work it's
because as human beings you have this
desire to do something to complete
something if you made a lot of money out
of your music morning I mean what does
almost a lot family to you yeah that's a
good question
have you made say millions of dollars no
are you a rich man
when you meet a rich what you mean you
have a lot of possessions a lot of money
in the bank
pause we shall make you rich I know I
don't have that type of richness my
richness is life
it was never about
what you love and then you'll learn how
to make money doing what you love that's
when I changed careers
I was never changing to something
the running I was changed into something
I love right and that to me that's
really the only way to keep the passion
if you have two choices one is playing a
piano and another one bowling
we can make more money bullying but you
love playing the piano more you got to
play the piano it's like you'll tear
yourself apart if you're not doing
you know what it is right now right now
there's something that you love more
than everything whatever it is it's
crazy
if you just focus on the money you're
never gonna get it this is what so many
entrepreneurs do and why so many
entrepreneurs fail is their number one
goal is money now money is important if
you're running a business money is
important you know even if you're
running a charity money's still
important money is important it's just
not the number one thing it's number 2
or 3 there has to be something more
important than money for you to have
success ultimate success as an
entrepreneur sure you can make a few
bucks but you look at the people at the
top in any field money was never the
number-one goal look at the people who
are self-made millionaires and
billionaires and read their biographies
and read their story and understand why
they started their companies watch the
top 10 videos on all of them it's never
been about the money it's always been
about making a profound change the way
something is done in their industry
having a deep passion for their craft
that they needed to bring this thing out
into creation you know when George Lucas
created Star Wars he thought it would be
a flop he thought it would only before a
select few geeks who really loved that
genre he never expected it to be this
huge thing that turned him into a
billionaire but he loved making a video
when he poured every ounce that
creativity had into making that movie
and that's a story over and over and
over and over and over again successful
entrepreneurs love their craft they want
to do the work and as a result of
creating something valuable because they
put so much love into it then they start
making money are you gonna get paid up
front from this from Lloyd Lloyd we're
gonna cut you a check
am I getting paid or frozenness you can
get me a get your check no but it's not
a it's not about it's not about money
for me like it's not it's not I wanted
to do I wanted my own Network I wanted
to put I wanted to do something cool and
it's always about just me doing
something that I think is awesome and
the money will come I'm not I'm not
worried about that that'll that'll come
when the universe decides for it to come
what I do love is if I can partner with
a brand who has the same goals and
values and and brand awareness as me
that's like when it becomes truly
organic because every brand I'll have
ever done has literally been the
ever like that they've ever done I am
the best in the world at integrating
brands into content and social media
there's no one better than I am and
that's because I carefully choose who
I'm gonna do it with and how I'm gonna
do it with Hannes was one of the first
big brand deals that I did that was like
okay like I have enough money to move to
Los Angeles and they let me do my thing
they gave me creative control Korea we
went back and forth but it's become just
this it's it's a flawless integration
into my life
but what what you're saying I think is
that you and your values have to be on
the same page
as the brand in its problems absolutely
has to otherwise otherwise I'm a sellout
otherwise I'm just doing social media
for money and I've never done that I
think that's also important I've never
I've never created content for money
like I love making videos and if a brand
can also increase or heighten the logan
paul brand the Maverick brand and make a
video that's shareable that helps me as
well it's not it's not just about the
money do not make any decisions based on
money none it's the worst way to make a
decision which I know is so hard to say
I mean I didn't grow up with any money
and I know so many of us are our
families have a lot at stake they put a
lot into us made a lot of sacrifices for
us and you say you don't have the luxury
of doing that but I actually think you
do you will be more successful if you
make decisions based upon what is going
to feed your soul make you feel value
valued validated you know have you
waking up in the morning and wasting to
work whatever it might be and I can tell
you after a short amount of time money
will not be enough at the end of the day
a bigger paycheck is another suit or
more real estate more square footage
that's what it comes down to you end up
with another room and a fuller closet
and after a while that's not going to do
it even if I wasn't making videos now I
I've learned that I should you should
really follow your heart and you should
do what you want to do and what you are
passionate about if I really it's hard
for me to talk about this but I really
was wasn't happy before because it felt
like I didn't enjoy what I was doing and
it felt like it didn't have a purpose of
me doing it so the future for me was
something really like ah I didn't even
want to think about it and I've learned
I learned a lot from this YouTube about
myself and that I always no matter what
I want to do what I what I love to do
and what I'm passionate about and I hope
I can carry that message on to you Bros
that I'm not saying school or anything
like that but you should definitely fall
to follow what you want to do absolutely
life is too short for doing things that
you don't like money is the topic that I
purposely try to avoid for the five
years that I've been making videos
because I just I just feel like it's not
important to anyone and I just want to
make entertaining videos don't get me
wrong though I don't hate money I'm not
gonna pretend like it doesn't matter to
me because it matters to everyone but
when I started doing YouTube I was in
college I was on a student loan I
couldn't even afford a proper computer
that I could record gameplay on so I was
lucky I managed to sell some artwork
that I made online and that's how I was
able to get started some of you know
this story but shortly after I quit
college and so I had to get a job and I
took whatever job I could get which was
to work in a hotdog stand and a lot of
people like to take this story as
something negative or like oh he did
that or I can't believe he used to sell
hotdogs now look at him making big bucks
it wasn't like that at all for me I was
the happiest I was at that time because
I was finally for the first time in many
many years doing what I wanted to do and
the fact that I could make videos was so
much more important to me that I had to
spend a few hours a day
doing a job that wasn't that prestigious
I didn't know you could be big yet well
I know people who were big at other type
of videos but there was no one big at
gaming and I didn't know you could make
money out of it so it was never like a
career that I just quit college to
pursue it's just something I just love
to do and here we are five years later
and it's it's exploded and what people I
guess don't really think about until
it's in their phase is that I have nine
billion views and that translates to
something there's ads in my videos I
make money out of those so whenever it
comes out how much I made a certain year
people just get so shocked and a lot of
people also which I saw were very very
angry they thought it was unfair they
thought I just sit on my ass all day and
I just yell at the screen over here
which is true but there's so much more
to it than that and I understand that
people just haters gonna hate right but
I don't know I I'd really think that
money doesn't make you happy I am just
as happy as I am now as I was five years
ago I'm I'm very happy that I don't have
to worry about paying rent because that
was a huge issue when my state came over
to Sweden we could barely afford it so
maybe about that but other than that it
doesn't change much that our love and
desire for material things can cause us
to miss the most important thing in life
people don't realize that money is
dangerous somebody says well what could
be dangerous about money it's what it
does it's the attitude people have that
if I have enough money I can go where I
want to go do what I want to do marry
who I want to marry wherever I want to
where Drive want to want to drive live
where I want to live eat where I want to
eat and on and on and on and go
that maybe some of the things that money
can do but that doesn't satisfy you but
think about this you can have all the
money in the world you want if you don't
have good health you can't buy it if
you're not listening if you don't have
anybody to love you can't buy it if you
don't have anyone who loves you you
can't buy it in other words you don't
you can't buy peace joy happiness
contentment and you serve I cannot buy
eternal life money can do some things
they can do many good things in the
right hands but it can't satisfy the
longing of your soul it can't satisfy
the longing of your heart thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
I love to know what did you think of
this video who had the most meaningful
message that you're going to immediately
apply to your thinking somehow let me
know leave in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Kat Harvey
Kat thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book and having me on your
youtube channel to do an interview I
really really appreciate it and I'm so
glad you enjoyed the book thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon raise your
standard Apple at the core this core
value is that means that people need
passion
[Music]
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's suppose to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details